Tuesday, Tucson, Arizona.
周二，亚利桑那州图森市。
How are you feeling?
你感觉怎么样？
I'm scared.
我很害怕。
Rediet Seifu moved to the United States from Ethiopia four months ago. She's learning English. And once a week, one of her teachers from the City High School in Tuscon, Sarah Bromer, takes her to Ike's coffee shop to practice a simple English conversation.
Rediet Seifu 四个月前从埃塞俄比亚搬到了美国。她正在学习英语。每周一次，她的一位老师，来自图森市城市高中的 Sarah Bromer 会带她去 Ike 咖啡店练习简单的英语对话。
It goes like this-- Rediet orders tea. That's it, actually. That's the whole thing. Usually, they walk past the door four or five times before she even gets the courage to go inside to do this. And they rehearse beforehand.
流程是这样的——Rediet 点杯茶。其实就是这样。整个过程就这么多。通常，她们会在门口徘徊四五次，她才有勇气走进去。而且她们会事先排练。
So she's going to go-- she calls everybody hon. Do you know what that means? Like honey?
她会去——她管所有人都叫“亲爱的”（hon）。你知道那是什么意思吗？就像“蜂蜜”（honey）一样？
Yeah.
是的。
Today, for the very first time, Ms. Bromer is making Rediet order without her help.
今天，Ms. Bromer 第一次让 Rediet 在没有她帮助的情况下点餐。
She might say, hey, hon, what do you want? Or I bet she'll say, hey, hon, what can I get for you? You'll say--
她可能会说，嘿，亲爱的，你要什么？或者我敢打赌她会说，嘿，亲爱的，我能为你点些什么？你会说——
I would like a tea, please.
我想来杯茶，谢谢。
And then what if she says, what? What? Pardon me?
那如果她说，什么？什么？请再说一遍？
A tea. You confused me.
一杯茶。你把我搞糊涂了。
Ms. Bromer's actually teasing Rediet by saying, "What?" She knows that this is Rediet's biggest fear, that people will not understand her, that they're going to say, what? What? What was that?
Ms. Bromer 其实是在逗 Rediet，故意说“什么？”。她知道这是 Rediet 最大的恐惧，怕别人听不懂她说话，怕他们会问，什么？什么？你说什么？
Well, that's what you're afraid of, right?
好吧，这就是你害怕的事情，对吧？
You confused me.
你把我搞糊涂了。
You're afraid, right, you're going to say, can I have a tea? And then she's going to go, what? What?
你很害怕，对吧，怕你会说，能给我杯茶吗？然后她会说，什么？什么？
Tea.
茶。
No, you're saying it just fine. She's going to know what you want. I'm just kidding. You'll say, I want a tea.
不，你说的挺好的。她会知道你想要什么的。我只是开个玩笑。你会说，我想要杯茶。
OK. I want a tea.
好的。我想要杯茶。
Good. She'll say, what kind do you want?
很好。她会说，你想要哪种？
Honeybush tea.
蜜树茶（Honeybush tea）。
Huh?
啊？
[GIGGLING]
[咯咯笑]
OK, they practice a few more times. And then, finally, Rediet approaches the counter.
好吧，她们又练习了几次。然后，终于，Rediet 走到柜台前。
Hello.
你好。
Hi.
嗨。
Have a good one.
祝你过得愉快。
Bye, guys.
再见，各位。
I would like a tea, please.
我想来杯茶，谢谢。
I'm sorry?
抱歉，你说什么？
OK, I just have to stop the tape right there. Did you hear? It happened. Exactly what she feared. The lady didn't understand her.
好吧，我得在这里暂停一下录音。你听到了吗？发生了。正是她所担心的。女士没听懂她的话。
And listen how she handles this. She's so good. Let's take that from the top again.
听听她是怎么处理的。她做得太棒了。让我们重新来一遍。
I would like a tea, please.
我想来杯茶，谢谢。
I'm sorry?
抱歉，你说什么？
I would like a tea, please.
我想来杯茶，谢谢。
Sure.
好的。
Hot tea.
热茶。
Hot tea?
热茶？
Yeah.
是的。
Do you know which kind you'd like, sweetheart?
你知道想要哪种吗，亲爱的？
Yeah, honeybush tea.
是的，蜜树茶。
Honeybush?
蜜树茶？
Yeah.
是的。
Anything else?
还要别的吗？
No.
没有。
OK.
好的。
She doesn't giggle. She doesn't panic. She's perfect.
她没有咯咯笑。她没有慌乱。她做得非常完美。
$1.69.
1.69 美元。
It's her first time buying something by herself in the US.
这是她第一次在美国独自购买东西。
And $0.06 is your change, honey.
这是找你的 0.06 美元零钱，亲爱的。
Welcome to America, Rediet. You bought something. You're engaging in commerce. You're talking to the lady at the counter.
欢迎来到美国，Rediet。你买到东西了。你在进行商业交易。你在和柜台后面的女士交流。
We are so glad to have you here. Have some tea. You'll be paying for it yourself.
我们很高兴有你在这里。喝点茶吧。是你自己付的钱哦。
I'm not scared.
我不害怕了。
You're not?
你不怕了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Really? You felt brave?
真的吗？你觉得勇敢了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I think you did a really good job.
嗯，我觉得你做得非常好。
Yeah, I think. Yeah.
是的，我也觉得。是的。
I'm Ira Glass. This week on our radio program, we're trying something unusual for us. This is the second time we've done this. Instead of our usual picking a theme and finding stories on the theme, the theme this week will simply be the week, the week that we all just lived through, these past seven days. Everything on the show has just happened, including stories that are so small and personal-- like, you know, Rediet ordering her first tea-- that they would never belong on a regular news show.
我是 Ira Glass。本周在我们的广播节目中，我们尝试了一些不寻常的做法。这是我们第二次这么做。我们没有像往常那样挑选一个主题并寻找相关故事，本周的主题就是这周本身，我们刚刚度过的这一周，过去的七天。节目中的一切都是刚刚发生的，包括那些非常细微和私人的故事——比如，Rediet 点她的第一杯茶——这些故事通常不会出现在常规新闻节目中。
And we have stories that are bigger, too, like this next woman, whose husband is Syrian. They lived there again in Syria till January, when it got too unstable. And she came to America, where she grew up. And then something bad happened.
我们也有一些更重大的故事，比如下一位女士，她的丈夫是叙利亚人。他们住在叙利亚，直到一月份，局势变得太不稳定。她回到了她长大的美国。然后发生了一些糟糕的事情。
I don't know. Really, I don't believe this could be happening. It seems like something that would happen in movies or in a book. We're just normal people.
我不知道。真的，我不相信这种事会发生。这看起来像是电影或书里才会有的情节。我们只是普通人。
Her husband's still in Syria. He owns some businesses there. And two of their employees were taken hostage by the rebel forces who are fighting President Bashar al-Assad. President Obama has called for him to step down, of course, on Thursday. The Pentagon warned him not to use chemical weapons.
她丈夫还在叙利亚。他在那里经营一些生意。他们的两名员工被反对派武装绑架了，那些反对派正在与巴沙尔·阿萨德总统作战。奥巴马总统周四当然呼吁他下台。五角大楼警告他不要使用化学武器。
Did you talk to your husband today?
你今天跟你丈夫通话了吗？
Yeah, I did.
是的，我打了。
What's the very latest?
最新情况是什么？
He told me this morning they said that they would accept $80,000, and my husband said OK.
他今天早上告诉我，他们说他们会接受 8 万美元，我丈夫说可以。
And you and I are talking on Wednesday.
我们是在周三通话的。
Yes. Yeah, I mean, I think their objective is to get the money and hopefully not to kill somebody in between.
是的。我是说，我想他们的目标是拿到钱，希望在此期间不要杀人。
And it must make you feel so strange to feel like, oh, and these people who you guys are negotiating with, those are the US allies in the war.
当你觉得，哦，这些人，你们正在谈判的对象，居然是美国在战争中的盟友，这一定让你感觉很奇怪吧。
Yeah. They're trying to clean up their act and get rid of this type of stuff, or appear like that. And I don't know--
是的。他们正试图洗心革面，摆脱这种事情，或者至少看起来是这样。我不知道——
So have you spent most of this week just, like, on pins and needles just to hear what the next thing is with these employees?
所以这周大部分时间你是不是都像坐在针毡上一样，就为了听关于这些员工的最新消息？
Yeah. I haven't slept because of this. So hopefully-- I don't know if you are familiar with how things work in the Middle East, but everything always takes forever.
是的。我因此彻夜难眠。所以希望——我不知道你是否熟悉中东的事情运作方式，但一切总是需要很长时间。
We don't really have 25 days. We have a few precious hours left. We are at a critical juncture.
我们其实没有 25 天。我们只剩下几个宝贵的小时了。我们处于关键时刻。
In Doha, Qatar, this week, at the latest United Nations Climate Change Conference, the main goal that they were trying to achieve seemed incredibly modest. The things that the world originally negotiated in 1997 in Kyoto about climate change are about to expire. If all goes as planned, the delegates here hope to recommit to them.
本周在卡塔尔多哈举行的最新一届联合国气候变化大会上，他们试图实现的主要目标看起来极其微小。世界 1997 年在京都就气候变化最初谈判达成的协议即将到期。如果一切按计划进行，这里的代表们希望重新承诺这些协议。
But their bigger mission-- for instance, limiting the increase in world temperature to 2 degrees Celsius, which the world's governments committed to in 2009 in Copenhagen-- is starting to seem impossible, meaning more hurricane Sandys, more drought, more floods more frequently. A typhoon called Bopha hit the Philippines on Tuesday with a death toll that'll probably be twice that of Hurricane Sandy. This man speaking is the lead negotiator from the Philippines, Naderev Sano, giving a speech that becomes, as you'll hear, very unusual for this deeply bureaucratic, diplomatic setting.
但他们更大的使命——例如，将世界气温上升限制在 2 摄氏度以内，这是世界各国政府 2009 年在哥本哈根承诺的——看起来开始变得不可能了，这意味着更多的桑迪飓风、更多的干旱、更频繁的洪水。周二，一场名为“宝霞”（Bopha）的台风袭击了菲律宾，死亡人数可能将是飓风桑迪的两倍。正在发言的这位男士是菲律宾首席谈判代表 Naderev Sano，正如你将听到的，他在这个极其官僚和外交的场合发表了一场非常不同寻常的演讲。
An important backdrop for my delegation is the profound impacts of climate change that we are already confronting. And as we see here, every single hour, even as we vacillate and procrastinate here, we are suffering. Madam Chair, we have never had a typhoon like Bopha, which has wreaked havoc in a part of the country that has never seen a storm like this in half a century.
对于我的代表团来说，一个重要的背景是我们已经面临的气候变化的深远影响。正如我们在这里看到的，每一小时，即使我们在这里犹豫不决和拖延，我们都在受苦。主席女士，我们从未经历过像“宝霞”这样的台风，它在我国一个半世纪以来从未见过此类风暴的地区造成了严重破坏。
Finally, Madam Chair, I'm making an urgent appeal, not as a negotiator, not as a leader of my delegation, but as a Filipino. I appeal to the whole world. I appeal to the leaders from all over the world to open our eyes to the stark reality that we face. I appeal to ministers.
最后，主席女士，我发出紧急呼吁，不是作为谈判代表，也不是作为代表团团长，而是作为一名菲律宾人。我向全世界呼吁。我呼吁世界各地的领导人睁开眼睛，面对我们所处的残酷现实。我呼吁部长们。
The outcome of our work is not about what our political masters want. It is about what is demanded of us by 7 billion people. I appeal to all-- please, no more delays. No more excuses. Please, let Doha be remembered as the place where we found the political will to turn things around.
我们工作的成果不是关于我们的政治主人们想要什么。而是关于 70 亿人民对我们的要求。我呼吁所有人——请，不要再推迟了。不要再有借口了。请让多哈被铭记为我们找到政治意愿来扭转局面的地方。
No choo-choo out of the train. No train whistle in the train. No doorbells.
火车没有呜呜声。火车上没有火车汽笛声。没有门铃。
As we poured gases into the atmosphere that are slowly heating the planet, threatening our very existence, we also put on plays for children and the disabled this week. In Montana, the Missoula Community Theatre prepared a special performance of the musical Miracle on 34th Street for people on the autism spectrum. This meant no sudden loud noises, lower lights, volunteers with glow sticks signaling when to applaud, and lower sound levels in general. Director Michael McGill discussed the changes with the cast before the show.
当我们把气体排入大气层，缓慢地加热地球，威胁到我们的生存时，我们这周也为儿童和残疾人举办了戏剧表演。在蒙大拿州，米苏拉社区剧院为患有自闭症谱系的人们准备了一场特别的音乐剧《34 街的奇迹》。这意味着没有突然的巨响，灯光调暗，志愿者用荧光棒示意何时鼓掌，整体音量降低。导演 Michael McGill 在演出前与演员讨论了这些变化。
Young people, when you come out for Donald Duck, you come out quickly, but you don't scream.
年轻人，当唐老鸭出场时，你们要快速出场，但不要尖叫。
Just know that Mrs. Sawyer's going to be very quiet in the trial scene.
只要知道 Sawyer 太太在审判场景中会非常安静就行了。
[GROANING]
[呻吟声]
OK, here we go. Our first group coming up. We've got Hype-- Hyphen. Y'all give it up for Hyphen. They're doing some step for us today. Give it up, give it up, give it up, give it up.
好了，我们开始吧。我们的第一组要上场了。我们有 Hype——Hyphen。大家为 Hyphen 加油。他们今天为我们展示一些步法。加油，加油，加油，加油。
At the Best of Both Worlds Dance and Step Competition in Charlottesville, Virginia, Akayla Brown, Aquasia Baker, and Destiny Grady, ages 10, 10, and 11, told reporter Eric Mennel that they were confident of winning, even though they were competing against college kids.
在弗吉尼亚州夏洛茨维尔举行的“最佳世界舞蹈和步法大赛”上，10 岁、10 岁和 11 岁的 Akayla Brown、Aquasia Baker 和 Destiny Grady 告诉记者 Eric Mennel，她们对获胜很有信心，尽管她们是在和大学生比赛。
And I think they'd be like, oh, we can just beat the little kids and this and that. They just think that they can just get in our Kool-Aid when they don't even know the flavor.
我想他们会觉得，哦，我们可以打败这些小孩子之类的。他们只是认为他们可以在不了解情况的情况下插手我们的事。
Ooh! That's a good one, [INAUDIBLE]
噢！那句说得好，[听不清]
That same day, in Newark, New Jersey, a stranger on the train that carries you between terminals at Newark Airport got into the Kool-Aid of a man named James Braly, asking where he was headed.
同一天，在新泽西州纽瓦克，在连接纽瓦克机场航站楼的火车上，一个陌生人插手了 James Braly 的事，问他要去哪里。
I am on my way to meet my brother-- or my half-brother, depending on how you look at it. The internet is a very, very strange thing.
我正在去见我兄弟的路上——或者说同父异母的兄弟，取决于你怎么看。互联网真是一件非常非常奇怪的事情。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
First day?
第一天？
For the first time.
第一次。
Seriously?
认真的吗？
I'm absolutely serious.
我非常认真。
The half-brother, Jan, who is from Norway, recently learned the name of his father for the very first time, did an internet search, discovered James' family in the United States, and was coming to meet them. The guy on the train asked James, what proof do you have? You going to get a DNA test or something?
这位来自挪威的同父异母兄弟 Jan 最近第一次得知了他父亲的名字，在网上搜索了一下，发现了 James 在美国的家人，正准备来见他们。火车上的那个人问 James，你有什么证据？你要去做 DNA 测试之类的吗？
Uh, not unless he asks me for a lot of money.
呃，除非他找我要一大笔钱。
When James gets to terminal A, he scans the crowd and spots him.
当 James 到达 A 航站楼时，他扫视人群，发现了对方。
I think that's him.
我想那就是他。
His half-brother's a 52-year-old man with a waxed handlebar mustache, hair thinned from chemo, and his dad's eyes. He is instantly recognizable, James says, as family.
他同父异母的兄弟是一个 52 岁的男人，留着打蜡的八字胡，因为化疗头发稀疏，有着他父亲的眼睛。James 说，一眼就能认出是家人。
Can I get you a drink?
我能给你买杯饮料吗？
Welcome to WBEZ Chicago. It's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. Coming up all this hour, stories of all kinds, from all over, all from the past seven days. Stay with us.
欢迎来到芝加哥 WBEZ。这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。接下来这一小时，我们将带来各种故事，来自各处，全部发生在这过去的七天里。请继续关注。
This past Saturday, the first of the seven days that we're covering in today's show, I Skyped with Hyder Akbar-- he's in Kabul, Afghanistan-- to find out if anything was happening there that might be interesting for the radio. Hyder's been on our show a few times. He grew up in California, but his family is from Afghanistan. After college, Hyder moved there.
上周六，我们今天报道的七天里的第一天，我和在阿富汗喀布尔的 Hyder Akbar 进行了 Skype 通话，想看看那里是否发生了什么对广播来说有趣的事情。Hyder 已经在我们的节目中出现过几次了。他在加州长大，但他的家族来自阿富汗。大学毕业后，Hyder 搬到了那里。
He said that one of the guys that he's close to, Josef, was thinking about traveling to Kunar Province. That's where he's from. This is an area that's been a Taliban stronghold in the past. It's on the border with Pakistan.
他说他亲近的人之一，Josef，正在考虑去库纳尔省。那是他家乡。过去这里一直是一个塔利班的据点。它在与巴基斯坦的边境上。
If the Afghan government were to lose control of the country to the Taliban, it would probably start in Kunar. And that's a real possibility-- civil war, the government falling. So what's happening in Kunar right now tells us whether that is in the cards in the future.
如果阿富汗政府失去对该国的控制，让塔利班占领，这很可能会从库纳尔开始。这是一个真实的可能性——内战，政府垮台。所以库纳尔现在发生的事情告诉我们这是否会在未来发生。
Let me grab Josef, who's here, who actually was trying to get my dad to let him go back home tomorrow. I can bring him in here and talk to him about what's going on.
让我叫一下 Josef，他就在这儿，其实他一直在试图让我爸让他明天回家。我可以把他叫过来，谈谈发生了什么。
That seems great. Yeah, bring him in.
那太好了。是的，带他过来。
What are you doing when you [INAUDIBLE]? OK, just a second. Let me--
你在做什么当[听不清]？好吧，稍等。让我——
So Josef shows up.
所以 Josef 出现了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC].
[讲阿拉伯语]。
And Hyder asks him what's happening in Kunar right now.
Hyder 问他库纳尔现在发生了什么。
[SPEAKING ARABIC].
[讲阿拉伯语]。
Oh. Oh. He says the most interesting thing is that the Americans have just pulled out of an area called Pashangar, in his area, where there was almost like a local militia with them and then the Americans controlling them. And they pulled out of that base. And now the problems have started.
哦。哦。他说最有趣的事情是美国人刚刚撤出了一个叫 Pashangar 的地区，也就是他的地区，那里曾经几乎有当地民兵和他们在一起，由美国人控制。他们撤出了那个基地。现在问题就开始了。
And they're warning everybody, they're telling everybody, look, the Americans are leaving. The Americans are out. We're coming for you guys. We're going to go after whoever cooperated with the Afghan government, with the Americans. You guys better be careful. And they've started attacking the Afghan National Army. That, he says, is the main thing going on right now.
他们警告所有人，他们告诉大家，看，美国人要走了。美国人走了。我们要来找你们了。我们要追究每一个与阿富汗政府、与美国人合作的人。你们最好小心点。他们已经开始攻击阿富汗国民军了。他说，这就是目前发生的主要事情。
Wow.
哇。
There might be a chance to get interesting audio there, too, that this might be of interest. So let's see. Let's see.
那里可能还有机会获得有趣的音频，这可能会引起关注。所以让我们看看。让我们看看。
So they went to see, in an ancient Toyota Corolla. They drove up there. They'd have to be careful, stay under the radar. A few days before, Hyder said, a few guys with the Afghan National Army were stopped on the road coming from Kunar and killed.
所以他们坐一辆古老的丰田花冠去看了看。他们开车上去了。他们得小心，保持低调。Hyder 说，几天前，几名阿富汗国民军士兵在从库纳尔回来的路上被拦住并杀害了。
They left on Tuesday. They were going to be back Tuesday night or Wednesday morning. Our plan was to talk again 6 o'clock Wednesday night, Kabul time.
他们周二出发。他们本打算在周二晚上或周三早上回来。我们的计划是喀布尔时间周三晚上 6 点再次通话。
Then, Wednesday, Hyder wasn't answering any emails or any phone calls. 6 o'clock came and went. I started to get worried. And then, after an hour or so, I saw that he was online, on Skype. So I tried him.
然后，周三，Hyder 没有回复任何邮件或电话。6 点过了，人也没出现。我开始担心了。然后，过了一个小时左右，我看到他在 Skype 上在线了。所以我联系了他。
[RING]
[响铃]
[SKYPE CALL STARTING]
[Skype 通话开始]
Hello?
喂？
Hyder?
Hyder？
Hey, Ira.
嘿，Ira。
So it's Wednesday, and you just got back from Kunar Province.
所以是周三了，你刚从库纳尔省回来。
Yes, I did. I just got back from Kunar. This was probably the most intense experience of my life a few hours ago. So that's kind of at the forefront of my mind.
是的。我刚从库纳尔回来。几个小时前这可能是我一生中最激烈的经历。所以这事儿占据了我的思绪。
What happened?
发生了什么？
I was coming back with a story. And I was very excited, driving down, taking in the view of Kunar, which is actually very scenic. So I had my headphones on. And I'm driving down.
我本想带个故事回来。我非常兴奋，开车下去，欣赏库纳尔的风景，实际上非常漂亮。我戴着耳机。我开车下去。
And I have Josef, who lives with me now and works with me. And Sartor, who you've been introduced to through the previous documentaries, was sitting in the back. And I wanted to drive myself.
我有 Josef，他现在和我一起住，和我一起工作。还有 Sartor，你通过之前的纪录片认识过他，坐在后面。我想自己开车。
And we were coming by this bend in the road where it slows down a little bit. And we were passing by that bend when, all of a sudden, somebody jumped up behind this wall. He jumped up behind the wall, and he tried stopped the car. He put his hand on the car twice, like-- [BANGING] --and yelled, stop.
我们来到路上的这个弯道，速度稍微慢了一点。我们刚经过那个弯道，突然，有人从墙后面跳出来。他跳到墙后面，试图拦住车。他两次把手放在车上，就像——[撞击声]——并喊道，停车。
And I had my headphones on, so I just looked through the corner of my eye. And I see confusion. And I see Josef next to me, yelling, go go, go! And I looked at him, and he had his AK-47 pointed straight at us.
我戴着耳机，所以我只是用眼角的余光看了看。我看到了混乱。我看到 Josef 在我旁边，喊道，快走，快走！我看着他，他把 AK-47 直接指着我们。
When he had his AK-47 pointed straight at us and I saw that, I just floored the accelerator. I floored the accelerator, and I was like, oh, not time to stop. And my music was still going on in my ears.
当他把 AK-47 直接指着我们时，我看到那一幕，我猛踩油门。我猛踩油门，我想，不是停车的时候。我的音乐还在耳朵里响着。
And then, all of a sudden, I just see firing. And they had a few men on that side of the road firing at our car, and then a few men on the other side of the road, as well, too, firing at our car. They're just emptying into our car.
然后，突然，我看到枪声。他们在路的那一边有几个人向我们的车开火，另一边也有几个人向我们的车开火。他们只是向我们的车扫射。
Josef is ducked down. Sartor is ducked down in the back. I had my head up, because I have to look at the road. Here, the tires go flat. They hit both tires. And as they hit both tires, I'm kind of looking up and trying to still make it. We're probably going a few hundred meters past them now.
Josef 蹲下了。Sartor 在后面蹲下了。我抬着头，因为我得看路。轮胎爆了。他们击中了两个轮胎。当他们击中两个轮胎时，我还在抬头想继续走。我们现在离他们大概有几百米远了。
And then, all of a sudden, I see another person jump out. And he had an RPG in his hand. And he's looking right at me, and I'm looking right at him. And he shot the RPG right at me. He shot the RPG at me.
然后，突然，我看到另一个人跳出来。他手里拿着 RPG。他正看着我，我也正看着他。他向我发射了 RPG。他向我发射了 RPG。
And I'm seeing this rocket come towards me, and I'm like, OK, it's fine. I've done enough here. I had a pretty fun life. Obviously, all of that went through my mind. I was like, OK, it's done. It's done. I'm done.
我看到这枚火箭向我飞来，我想，好吧，没问题。我在这一生已经做了足够多了。我过得很有趣。显然，所有这些想法都闪过了我的脑海。我想，好吧，结束了。结束了。我完了。
And the RPG-- this is why everybody was so shocked. So at that second, we hit like a little bump on the road. And the RPG goes straight through the engine of my car, instead of coming directly at me. So it hits the engine right in front of me.
然后 RPG——这就是为什么每个人都如此震惊。就在那一秒，我们撞到了路上的一个小坑。RPG 直接穿过了我的引擎，而不是直接飞向我。所以它击中了我不正前方的引擎。
And is the car on fire? Are you in danger of the car blowing up?
车着火了吗？你有车爆炸的危险吗？
[INAUDIBLE] the engine on fire at this point. [INAUDIBLE] being able to take a picture later on. I could probably email this to you later on. But I'm going to show you on webcam real quick. You might be able to get a sense of how damaged it was and--
[听不清] 引擎此时着火了。[听不清] 能够稍后拍张照片。我稍后可能会通过电子邮件发给你。但我现在通过摄像头给你快速看一下。你可能能感觉到它损坏有多严重，而且——
OK. All right, you're holding this up to the webcam. We're talking over Skype.
好的。好吧，你把它举到摄像头前了。我们正在通过 Skype 通话。
Yeah. Can you see the car?
是的。你能看到车吗？
Oh my god. So the whole front is dented in. And then is the windshield busted in? It's hard to see.
天哪。整个车头都凹进去了。挡风玻璃碎了吗？很难看清。
Everything's busted in. The whole car went on fire. Do you see that hole right there?
所有东西都碎了。整辆车都着火了。你看到那边的那个洞了吗？
Yeah. So there's a huge hole in the driver's side in the front, on the hood.
是的。驾驶座前面车盖上有一个巨大的洞。
[INAUDIBLE] right now. Yeah, that's where the RPG went through. And you're looking at it in reverse right now, I think, because of the cam. But that's basically where I was sitting, right above it.
[听不清] 现在。是的，那就是 RPG 穿过的地方。我想因为摄像头的关系，你现在看到的应该是反过来的。但基本上就是我坐的地方，在它正上方。
And that's where the RPG came through. And that's where I missed the bump of the RPG. I mean, he was aiming straight at me. Like I said, when I saw that RPG come at me, I thought it was done. So--
那就是 RPG 进来的地方。那就是我躲过 RPG 的地方。我是说，他是直接瞄准我的。就像我说的，当我看到 RPG 向我飞来时，我以为完了。所以——
So the car is on fire. You guys are in the car. These guys are shooting just a couple of hundred meters behind you. And maybe have they stopped at that point?
车着火了。你们还在车里。这些人还在离你们几百米远的地方射击。他们当时停下了吗？
So at this point, it's quiet for a second. We're all kind of looking around. Right then, these two pickup trucks of ANA soldiers are driving by on the opposite side, going in their direction.
此时，安静了一秒钟。我们都在四处张望。就在那时，两辆装满阿富汗国民军士兵的皮卡车从对面开过，正朝他们的方向走。
This is the Afghan army. This is friendly to you--
这是阿富汗军队。这队人对你们很友好——
The Afghan National Army, yeah. So we see the Afghan National Army, two pickup trucks, plenty of guys in there. So we're like, OK-- phew-- coast clear. The ANA's going to be able to take care of this. And we get kind of relieved for a second.
阿富汗国民军，是的。我们看到阿富汗国民军，两辆皮卡车，里面有很多人。所以我们想，好吧——呼——危险解除了。阿富汗国民军应该能处理这件事。我们稍微松了一口气。
We get out of the car, we just see the ANA drive off. They saw it. They saw our car on fire. They definitely heard the RPG his us, because that doesn't make low noise.
我们下车，看到阿富汗国民军开车走了。他们看见了。他们看见我们的车着火了。他们肯定听到了 RPG 击中我们，因为那动静不小。
They heard the gunfire. And they just drive off. They just drive off, and I'm like, OK. All right.
他们听到了枪声。他们就直接开车走了。他们就这样走掉了，我心想，好吧。好吧。
They drive off in the direction of the guys who are shooting at you, or just in some other direction?
他们是朝开枪的方向走，还是朝其他方向走？
No, past them. Past them. Past them. They were driving in that direction, and they kept driving. So at this point, Josef just runs off. Josef has run off. He's a good hundred meters away from us at this point.
不，经过他们。经过他们。经过他们。他们朝着那个方向开去，然后一直走。此时，Josef 直接跑掉了。Josef 跑了。他此时离我们有足足一百米远。
And me and Sartor are kind of just looking at the car on fire, and we're like, what the hell? And we're looking at it, and Josef's screaming, get the hell out of here! Get the hell out of here!
我和 Sartor 只是看着车着火，我们想，到底怎么回事？我们看着它，Josef 在尖叫，快他妈离开这里！快他妈离开这里！
And I just looked at Sartor, and I was like, dude, my laptop bag's in there. Everything's in there. So we both run in. We open the door to go inside to grab the laptop bag out of it, with my laptop and other stuff in there.
我看着 Sartor，我说，伙计，我的笔记本电脑包在里面。所有东西都在里面。所以我们俩都跑过去。我们打开门进去拿笔记本包，我的笔记本电脑和其他东西都在里面。
And so as we do that, they start firing again. Luckily, the car covered us. And the bullets just hit the back of the car as we were on the side of the car trying to get the laptop bag out. We managed to get the laptop bag out. And then I'm kind of hiding behind the car.
当我们这样做时，他们又开始开火了。幸运的是，车身保护了我们。当我们试图在车边拿笔记本包时，子弹击中了车尾。我们成功拿到了笔记本包。然后我就躲在车后面。
I take out my iPhone, because I'm like, OK, I've got to record this a little bit, at least, for you guys. I was like, I want to record this thing. This is an interesting thing. I look at my iPhone. It has, like, 1% battery, 2%. I'm like, [BLEEP].
我掏出我的 iPhone，因为我想，好吧，我至少得为你们录下来。我想，我要录下这个东西。这是一件有趣的事。我看着我的 iPhone。它大概只有 1% 的电量，2%。我想，[脏话]。
So I have this on record, and I see Josef just come running back down. And it was kind of funny. He's like, what are you doing? I'm like, I need to record the car, I need to record the car for the thing. Remember, we came here to do the radio thing.
所以我录下来了，然后我看到 Josef 跑回来了。挺滑稽的。他说，你在干什么？我说，我得录下这辆车，我得为那个节目录下这辆车。记得吗，我们来这里是为了做广播节目的。
And he cursed you guys out and punched the hood. And basically, he said, F This American Life. What the hell are you going to do with This American Life when you're dead? And he started dragging me away.
他骂了你们，并重重地打了一下车盖。基本上，他说，去他妈的《美国生活》。你死后对《美国生活》能做什么？他开始把我拉走。
And right then, the phone turned off too. The phone turned off too, so it didn't save the recording, either. And he's dragging me away. As he's dragging me away--
就在那时，手机也关机了。手机也关机了，所以录音也没保存下来。他把我拉走。当他把我拉走时——
OK, soon after this in the conversation, I let Hyder know that if he is ever again in any situation where he might get killed, it is OK if he runs away and stops recording for the radio show. So he explained that they went around the bend. They saw two civilian cars stopped there. They were still being shot at. So they got into those cars. They got away.
好的，在谈话的稍后，我让 Hyder 知道，如果他再次遇到任何可能被杀的情况，他完全可以逃跑，停止为广播节目录音。所以他解释说，他们绕过了弯道。他们看到两辆民用汽车停在那里。他们仍在被射击。所以他们钻进那些车里。他们逃走了。
This was the first time, Hyder said, that somebody specifically tried to kill him. And he thinks that they wanted him because they were letting other cars pass by on the road, and they specifically tried to stop his car. But who was it who was targeting him? And why were they targeting him? That wasn't clear to him at all.
Hyder 说，这是第一次有人专门试图杀他。他认为他们想要他是因为他们让其他车辆从路上经过，却专门试图拦住他的车。但究竟是谁在针对他？为什么针对他？对他来说根本不清楚。
That's something I'm going to have to think about and figure out tonight, in the next couple of days.
这是我今晚和接下来几天得好好想想并弄清楚的事情。
Well, what are the possibilities? List through right now, tick off a couple of possibilities, just so I understand. What could it be?
好吧，可能性有哪些？列举一下，快速列举几种可能性，这样我能理解。会是什么呢？
It could have been the Taliban. It could have been the Taliban, who might have been following me a lot more closely than I realized, following my locations, where I'm spending the night, where I'm living. They definitely knew exactly where I was. I can't think of anything personal, in terms of any personal feuds, et cetera. So it'd be most likely the Taliban or people in Kunal that are with the insurgency that don't see me, I guess, as a threat.
可能是塔利班。可能是塔利班，他们可能比我意识到的跟踪得更紧，跟踪我的位置，我在哪里过夜，在哪里生活。他们绝对知道我确切在哪里。我想不出任何个人的事，比如任何私人恩怨等等。所以最可能是塔利班或库纳尔那些反叛势力的人，我猜他们并不认为我是个威胁。
And Hyder, is it as simple as you and your dad aren't necessarily so crazy about the current government in Afghanistan, but they know you definitely do not like the Taliban? And is it as simple as that?
Hyder，是不是很简单，你和你父亲不一定那么喜欢阿富汗现政府，但他们确实知道你绝对不喜欢塔利班？就是这么简单吗？
Almost as simple as that. The one thing I would add onto that is they could see us as being even more of a threat because we're not that close to this government anymore, because we don't approve of many things that are going on in the government. They can sideline a lot of other people very easily by saying, oh, these guys are corrupted individuals, involved with the government, fattening their pockets. But when they see me driving around in a [BLEEP] Corolla and just talking to people, engaging them, and being pretty sincere in my efforts, that's seen as much more of a threat, because they could delegitimize the Afghan government and the officials involved with them much easier.
几乎就这么简单。我要补充的一点是，他们可能会认为我们是更大的威胁，因为我们不再与这个政府那么亲近了，因为我们不赞成政府中发生的许多事情。他们可以很容易地通过说，哦，这些人是腐败分子，参与政府，中饱私囊，来边缘化许多其他人。但当他们看到我开着一辆[脏话]花冠车到处走，只是和人们谈话，与他们接触，并且在努力方面相当真诚时，这被视为更大的威胁，因为他们可以更容易地使阿富汗政府和参与其中的官员失去合法性。
And it's not crazy to think that Hyder is now at a point where he would be worth killing. His family's from Kunar. His father and uncle were in the insurgency in Kunar that drove out the Soviets in the 1980s. When the current Afghan government came to power after September 11, Hyder's dad was appointed governor of Kunar. They have friends there. They have a base of support.
认为 Hyder 现在处于一个值得被杀的地步并不疯狂。他的家族来自库纳尔。他的父亲和叔叔在 20 世纪 80 年代在库纳尔的反叛势力中赶走了苏联人。9/11 事件后，当现任阿富汗政府上台时，Hyder 的父亲被任命为库纳尔省长。他们在那里有朋友。他们有支持基础。
And as the Americans pull out in the next two years, there's going to be a power vacuum in the country. And people are getting in position for that, including Hyder. He is setting himself up to do politics. The way that he explains it, he says he wants to be the Afghan equivalent of a congressman, though with a militia. You need a militia, because it's Afghanistan.
随着美国人在未来两年撤出，这个国家将出现权力真空。人们正在为此做准备，包括 Hyder。他正在为从政做准备。按照他的解释，他说他想成为阿富汗版的国会议员，尽管需要民兵。你需要民兵，因为这是阿富汗。
We talked for a while. Hyder insisted that he is planning on going back to Kunar soon. And he's going to do it just like he did this time, in another beat-up old car, to prove that they didn't scare him, to prove that he wasn't going to stay away, which I really hope that his mom and his dad and his uncle talk him out of. And then we finally got to the reason for his trip in the first place, the story that he was so excited to bring back, that he ended up risking his life for, of what was happening in the province.
我们谈了一会儿。Hyder 坚持说他计划很快回库纳尔。他会像这次一样，开着另一辆破旧的老车去，证明他们没吓倒他，证明他不会远离，我真的希望他的妈妈、爸爸和叔叔能劝阻他。最后我们终于回到了他旅行的初衷，那个他如此兴奋地带回来，最终为此冒着生命危险的故事，关于该省正在发生什么。
So just review the highlights for me. So let's talk about what you saw when you were there. What's interesting?
所以请为我回顾一下亮点。让我们谈谈你在那里看到了什么。有什么有趣的？
OK, so we drove up there. We drove up there yesterday. And we went into the Pesh Valley.
好吧，我们开车上去了。我们昨天开车上去了。我们进入了佩什山谷（Pesh Valley）。
It's actually kind of funny. So the Pesh Valley's sort of like the valley of death. It was the place that was considered very dangerous. And some interesting new dynamics have emerged there with the ANA, the Afghan National Army.
其实挺逗的。佩什山谷有点像死亡之谷。它曾经被认为非常危险。那里出现了一些有趣的动态，关于阿富汗国民军（ANA）。
Again, this is the government's army. This for the government of Afghanistan.
重申一下，这是政府的军队。这是为了阿富汗政府。
The ANA, the Afghan National Army, is in control there now. The Americans have pulled out. What's going on because of that is that a lot of people, especially the civilian population, is siding with the ANA now. The ANA is just culturally much more aware. They've been able to make inroads amongst the population.
阿富汗国民军现在控制那里。美国人撤走了。因为这个，很多事情正在发生，很多人，特别是平民人口，现在站在国民军这一边。国民军在文化上更具意识。他们能够深入人口中。
They've been able to push the Taliban out, especially from the main roads. I was driving by areas where people used to get stopped and beheaded, government officials or those considered working with the Americans, driving past all of these potholes in the road where they had laid down IEDs. And that was fine. It was fine. And we're all taking in the scenery.
他们能够把塔利班赶走，特别是在主要道路上。我开车经过人们曾经被拦住并斩首的地方，政府官员或那些被认为与美国人合作的人，开车经过路上那些他们埋下简易爆炸装置（IED）的坑坑洼洼。那没问题。没问题。我们都在欣赏风景。
And it was a very heartwarming story, actually. I was actually very excited to come back. I was kind of aware, I was like, OK, maybe good news is not always that fun to report about. I was like, but it'll be exciting to finally come back. And I was very hopeful and feeling pretty jolly.
这其实是一个非常暖心的故事。我其实很兴奋能回来。我有点意识到，我想，好吧，也许好消息并不总是那么有趣报道。我想，但最终回来会很令人兴奋。我非常有希望，感觉相当愉快。
Because it was so hopeful that the Afghan National Army was doing a decent job?
因为阿富汗国民军做得不错，所以很有希望？
Exactly. Exactly, that there's hope for this country, there's hope for security in this country, there's hope for stability in this country. And as somebody who has spent the last 10 years involved in this place, that was incredible news for me.
正是。正是，这个国家有希望，这个国家的安全有希望，这个国家的稳定有希望。作为过去 10 年一直参与这个地方的人，这对我是不可思议的好消息。
Hyder Akbar. He's the author of  the book Come Back to Afghanistan. This song that's playing right now is one that he swears was playing on his iPod when he was ambushed. And it's such a weird choice that it's hard to believe that he'd make that up. It's the Geto Boys' 1991 hit, "Mind Playing Tricks On Me."
Hyder Akbar。他是《回到阿富汗》一书的作者。现在播放的这首歌，他发誓在他遭到伏击时，他的 iPod 里正在播放这首歌。这是一个如此奇怪的选择，以至于很难相信他是编出来的。这是 Geto Boys 1991 年的热门歌曲《Mind Playing Tricks On Me》。
[MUSIC - "MIND PLAYING TRICKS ON ME" BY GETO BOYS]
[音乐 - GETO BOYS 的《MIND PLAYING TRICKS ON ME》]
Well, if you live in a part of the country that has already had snow this year, you may find it hard to relate to the thrill experienced by some people in Arizona this past week. Lisa Pollak explains.
好吧，如果你住在今年已经下过雪的地区，你可能很难理解过去一周亚利桑那州一些人经历的那种兴奋。Lisa Pollak 解释道。
When I heard that an outdoor mall in Tuscon was promising snow on Saturday, a day when the high temperature hit 77 degrees, I figured there were only two possible explanations-- a pre-Christmas meteorological miracle or a ski resort style snow machine. But there was, in fact, a third option. I heard about it from Melanie Sutton, the senior marketing manager at La Encantada mall, the mall that sponsors the annual event known as the Enchanted Snowfall. She said that what we were about to see falling from sky that night was a desert style snow.
当我听说图森的一家户外购物中心承诺周六会有雪时——那天最高气温达到 77 华氏度（约 25 摄氏度）——我想只有两种可能的解释——一场圣诞前的气象奇迹，或者滑雪场式的造雪机。但实际上，还有第三种选择。我是从 Melanie Sutton 那里听说的，她是 La Encantada 购物中心的资深营销经理，该商场赞助了被称为“迷人降雪”的年度活动。她说那天晚上我们从天空中看到的飘落物是一种沙漠式的雪。
As our tagline, we say, "98% magic, 2% soap."
我们的口号是，“98% 的魔法，2% 的肥皂”。
Oh, wow. So it literally is, like, that's the ingredient, is soap? I mean, besides the magic.
哦，哇。所以它字面上就是，那就是成分，肥皂？我是说，除了魔法之外。
Correct. The ingredient is soap. But they're shaped as snowflakes.
正确。成分是肥皂。但它们被塑造成雪花的形状。
Got that? Me, neither. But minutes later, along with hundreds of parents and kids in the mall's open-air courtyard, I had a chance to see it for myself.
明白了吗？我也没有。但几分钟后，和商场露天庭院里的数百名父母和孩子一起，我有机会亲眼看到了。
Oh, oh, here we go.
哦，哦，我们开始吧。
"Oh, oh, here we go," I heard one of the dads say. Then there was a whooshing sound, followed by white stuff falling from the sky.
“哦，哦，我们要开始了，”我听到一位爸爸说。然后传来一阵呼啸声，接着白色的东西从天而降。
It's snowing!
下雪了！
From a distance, I can report that it did indeed resemble snow-- heavy, white flakes lit up by spotlights in the darkness. Up close, though, it was hard to be fooled. Imagine little clumps of bath suds or globs of latte foam, with a faintly fresh smell.
从远处看，我可以报告它确实很像雪——在聚光灯照射下，黑暗中重重的白色雪花。近距离看，却很难被骗过。想象一下一小团沐浴露或拿铁泡沫，带有一种淡淡的清新气味。
There it is, look!
就在那儿，看！
This man is talking to his three-year-old son, Cameron, who at first seemed to be saying how much he liked the snow--
这位男士正在和三岁的儿子 Cameron 说话，他起初看起来好像在说他多么喜欢这场雪——
I don't like snow.
我不喜欢雪。
You like snow.
你喜欢雪。
--but on closer examination, was actually saying how much he didn't like the snow.
——但仔细观察，他其实是在说他有多么不喜欢这场雪。
Don't like snow.
不喜欢雪。
It's OK.
没事的。
I don't like snow.
我不喜欢雪。
It's OK.
没事的。
Cameron was the exception. All around me, kids seemed to be going insane with joy. Over by the Apple store, a group of them had planted themselves under one of the faux snow machines and seemed to be trying to get as much white foam on their hair and clothes as possible. Others ran around with outstretched hands, trying to catch enough to make mushy snowballs and smash it on each other's heads.
Cameron 是个例外。我周围的孩子们似乎兴奋得要发疯了。在苹果商店旁边，一群人把自己安放在其中一台仿造雪机下，似乎试图让尽可能多的白色泡沫落在他们的头发和衣服上。其他人张开双手跑来跑去，试图接住足够的泡沫来制作糊状的雪球，然后砸在彼此头上。
[CHILD LAUGHING]
[儿童笑声]
My hair!
我的头发！
One boy walked up to me with a mass of suds in each hand and a look on his face like he couldn't believe his good fortune.
一个小男孩走过来，两只手里拿着一大团泡沫，脸上带着一种难以置信的幸运表情。
Look at how much snow I have.
看看我有多少雪。
Suddenly I felt a sense of duty. Shouldn't these kids know the truth? I would break it to them gently.
突然我感到一种责任感。难道这些孩子不应该知道真相吗？我会温柔地告诉他们。
It looks kind of like soap.
它看起来有点像肥皂。
That's because it is soap. It's kind of like regular snow. But if it gets in your eyes, your eyes just terribly burn. It's just bubbles, but I can't believe it! I've never seen this happen before!
那是因为它就是肥皂。它有点像普通的雪。但如果它进了你的眼睛，你的眼睛就会剧烈刺痛。它只是气泡，但我不敢相信！我从来没见过这种事发生！
So fun! And it's soap!
太有趣了！而且它是肥皂！
I tasted it. It tastes like soap.
我尝了一下。尝起来像肥皂。
About halfway through the show, I noticed I was starting to cough. And I wasn't the only one. I overheard this lady talking to her husband. Everyone's coughing, she said.
节目进行到一半，我注意到我开始咳嗽了。我不是唯一一个。我无意中听到这位女士和她丈夫说话。每个人都在咳嗽，她说。
We're all going to get cancer.
我们都会得癌症的。
What did you say?
你说什么？
We're all going to get cancer.
我们都会得癌症的。
Why did you say-- [COUGHS]
你为什么说——[咳嗽声]
Just listen. Everybody's standing here coughing, right? So it can't be good for you.
听着。每个人都站在这里咳嗽，对吧？所以这对你肯定没好处。
[COUGHS]
[咳嗽声]
Yeah. Right? There you go. There you go. Get you some.
是的。对吧？就是这样。就是这样。你也来点。
I checked with Melanie, the mall's marketing manager. She assured me that whatever was in the bubbles had been tested and was nontoxic. Though I believed her, I was a little relieved when the Enchanted Snowfall powered down after 15 minutes. Like a lot of things about the holidays, it was at its best from a distance, and a little went a long way.
我向商场的营销经理 Melanie 确认了。她向我保证，气泡里的任何成分都经过测试且无毒。尽管我相信她，但当 15 分钟后“迷人降雪”停止时，我还是感到有点解脱。就像假期里的很多事情一样，它在远距离看时最好，少一点反而更有趣。
Lisa Pollak. Coming up, a guy walks into a bar-- usually not a life-or-death situation. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
Lisa Pollak。接下来，一个人走进酒吧——这通常不是生死攸关的情况。那将在来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际的节目中，稍后回来继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. This week, instead of the usual sort of theme we do on our show, our theme is just the seven days that have just passed. We have stories, small and personal, and big and national, and international.
这是《美国生活》。我是 Ira Glass。本周，我们没有像往常那样做任何主题，我们的主题就是刚刚过去的七天。我们有小而私人的故事，有宏大而全国性的，还有国际性的故事。
Monday, you probably heard, House Speaker John Boehner issued his counterproposal to avoid the fiscal cliff. It was promptly rejected by the White House. By Wednesday, there were front-page stories that Republican leaders are considering a fallback plan to extend tax cuts to the middle class now, fight about the rest of it in January or February.
周一，你可能听说过，众议院议长 John Boehner 发表了他的反提案以避免财政悬崖。该方案立即被白宫否决。到了周三，头版故事说共和党领导人正在考虑一个后备计划，即现在延长中产阶级的减税政策，在一月或二月再为剩下的部分进行争论。
Also this week, Boehner cracked the whip in his own party. Republicans who didn't vote his way lost committee assignments. He warned to other House members that he would be watching. To put all of this in perspective, I called veteran Congress-watcher Norman Ornstein, who happened to be in Prague when I phoned him. His official title is Resident Scholar at the American Enterprise Institute.
同样在本周，Boehner 在他自己的党内挥舞鞭子。没有按他方式投票的共和党人失去了委员会职务。他警告其他众议院成员，他会看着他们的。为了全面了解这一切，我打电话给资深国会观察员 Norman Ornstein，我打电话时他恰好在布拉格。他的正式头衔是美国企业研究所的常驻学者。
But all I care about is that you mention the book--
但我只关心你提到那本书——
And the title of the book is?
那本书的标题是？
--which is, It's Even Worse Than It Looks-- How the American Constitutional System Collided with the New Politics of Extremism.
——也就是，《情况比看起来更糟——美国宪法体系如何与极端主义的新政治相碰撞》。
Consider it mentioned.
算提到过了。
OK.
好的。
So you're in Prague this week. Isn't this kind of a big week not to be near Capitol Hill for somebody like you?
所以你这周在布拉格。对于像你这样的人来说，这周难道不是不待在国会山附近太重要了吗？
It's a good week to be away from Capitol Hill in a lot of ways.
在很多方面，这确实是个离开国会山的好日子。
How so?
怎么说？
Well, it seems like a big week. But the fact is we're in the middle of an end game. And I've been kind of bemused by all of the focus on the every-minute maneuvering of Speaker John Boehner and President Obama, including a heavy focus on the fact that Boehner didn't pose for a picture with the President at the White House Christmas party.
嗯，这看起来好像是重要的一周。但事实是，我们正处于终局博弈之中。我对人们过于关注众议院议长 John Boehner 和奥巴马总统的每一分钟博弈感到好笑，包括重点关注 Boehner 没有在白宫圣诞派对上与总统合影。
And there's one important principle to keep in mind. When does an end game end? At the end. And the end is not this week.
记住一个重要的原则。终局博弈什么时候结束？在最后。而现在并不是最后。
Are you basically saying that this is a week we might as well ignore the news from Capitol Hill?
你是说这周我们最好忽略国会山的新闻吗？
Yes. I'm saying that there are naturally going to be people who follow every little twist and turn. But it doesn't really matter.
是的。我是说自然会有关注每一个微小曲折的人。但这并不重要。
So this is the thing that I was wondering, is, when you look at this maneuvering, can you tell how it's going to play out?
这就是我好奇的地方，当你观察这种博弈时，你能看出它会如何发展吗？
The answer is two-fold. The first part is, no, you can't tell how it's going to play out. But all of these ploys and, in some ways, histrionics are par for the course. So taking the temperature on any one of them doesn't really tell us that much.
答案有两个方面。第一部分是，不，你看不出它会如何发展。但所有这些策略，某种程度上甚至是做戏，都是家常便饭。所以仅仅关注其中任何一个并没有告诉我们太多。
Now, what I would have to say, though, is the second point. And it's frankly a giant caveat here. We are going through the most dysfunctional politics I've seen in 43 years. So I think there's a pretty good chance we'll get a patchwork deal to get us past this dilemma before the end of the year.
现在，我不得不说的是第二点。坦率地说，这里有一个巨大的告诫。我们正在经历我 43 年来见过最功能失调的政治。所以我认为我们很有可能在今年年底前达成一项拼凑协议来摆脱这个困境。
But I also think that there's a substantial chance, much higher than it would have been if we were looking at the process 20 years ago or 10 years ago, even 5 years ago, that we'll slip over into January. And it might take a jolt, a serious jolt, from the markets to bring us to some kind of conclusion here.
但我也认为有很大的可能性，比我们 20 年前、10 年前甚至 5 年前看待这个过程时要高得多，我们会拖到一月。这可能需要一次冲击，来自市场的严重冲击，才能让我们在这里达成某种结论。
Norman Ornstein. I asked him, why do they even bother going through the theater this week? Why not just skip to the part where they actually hammer out the deal? His answer, I thought, was interesting.
Norman Ornstein。我问他，他们为什么还要费心在本周做戏？为什么不直接跳到他们真正敲定协议的那一部分？我觉得他的回答很有趣。
He said that the Republicans need to demonstrate to Grover Norquist and Rush Limbaugh and all their own constituents that they tried everything, their back is against the wall, there was no other choice before they can raise taxes. The Democrats have their own version of it. They have to demonstrate to their base they had no choice but to cut entitlements before any deal. Both sides need to say no, he says, for a while.
他说共和党人需要向 Grover Norquist、Rush Limbaugh 和他们自己所有的选民证明，在提高税收之前，他们尝试了一切，背水一战，别无选择。民主党人也有他们自己的版本。他们必须向他们的基本盘证明，在达成任何协议之前，他们除了削减福利别无选择。双方都需要说不，他说，持续一段时间。
Wednesday night, New Orleans, French Quarter. A 25-year-old blonde girl named Joni Cooper is going up to everybody in this bar, asking a question that you probably wouldn't expect to hear on a night out drinking.
周三晚上，新奥尔良，法国区。一个名叫 Joni Cooper 的 25 岁金发女孩走到这家酒吧的每个人面前，问了一个你可能没料到会在酒吧喝酒之夜听到的问题。
Hey, guys.
嘿，伙计们。
How are you?
你们好吗？
Can I come chat with you?
我能和你们聊聊吗？
Sure.
当然。
Well, my name's Joni. And I'm here with NO/AIDS. We're doing free HIV testing today. Would y'all maybe be interested in getting tested tonight?
嗯，我叫 Joni。我代表 NO/AIDS 组织。我们今天在做免费 HIV 检测。你们今晚可能有兴趣检测一下吗？
NO/AIDS is an organization in Louisiana that works to prevent and reduce the spread of HIV and help treat people who are infected. Louisiana has the fourth highest estimated AIDS rate in the country. In 2011, nearly 60% of new HIV diagnoses in Louisiana were gay man. 74% were African Americans. So NO/AIDS tries to make finding at your HIV status as convenient as they possibly can, which means, for them, going into bars, asking people to put down their drink for 15 minutes, and come get tested. They get the results on the spot.
NO/AIDS 是路易斯安那州的一个组织，致力于预防和减少艾滋病毒的传播，并帮助治疗感染者。路易斯安那州的艾滋病发病率估计在全国排名第四。2011 年，路易斯安那州近 60% 的艾滋病毒新诊断病例是男同性恋者。74% 是非裔美国人。所以 NO/AIDS 试图尽可能方便地让人们了解他们的艾滋病毒状况，这意味着对他们来说，要走进酒吧，请求人们放下手中的饮料 15 分钟，来接受检测。他们当场就能得到结果。
It's my birthday, so--
今天是我的生日，所以——
[SCREAMS]. Happy birthday!
[尖叫声]。生日快乐！
Joni is pitching a group of guys who are out for their friend's 30th birthday. You might think this would not be a receptive crowd, but listen to what happens.
Joni 正在游说一群出来为朋友庆祝 30 岁生日的男士。你可能认为这不会是一个乐于接受的群体，但听听发生了什么。
You're doing it right now? Like, what time?
你们现在就做？比如说，什么时候？
We're doing it right now.
我们现在就做。
Let's do it.
我们做吧。
You want to go?
你想去吗？
Let's go.
我们走吧。
All right!
好的！
Let's go. I'm going to get tested. You coming?
走吧。我要去检测。你来吗？
Where?
在哪？
Right here, right now.
就在这儿，就在现在。
You catch someone by surprise. You kind of catch someone off guard, and they're like, oh, well, I guess it's here. I've never done it.
你让某人感到惊讶。你有点让他们措手不及，他们会想，哦，好吧，我想是在这里吧。我从来没做过。
Robin Pearce runs the testing program, which has testing sites all over New Orleans, not just in bars.
Robin Pearce 负责这项检测计划，在整个新奥尔良都有检测点，不仅在酒吧。
The statistic is that 1.2 million people in the United States are living with HIV, and one in five of them don't know they have it. So finding the people who don't know that they have HIV is the point of what we're doing.
统计数据是，美国有 120 万人携带艾滋病毒，其中五分之一的人不知道自己携带病毒。所以寻找不知道自己感染了艾滋病毒的人就是我们所做工作的重点。
The week that we're covering here today happened to begin with World AIDS Day. And thinking about that, we sent out a writer, Nathaniel Rich, to watch the HIV testing at one of the highest risk venues NO/AIDS tests at-- Club New Orleans, a five-story sex club for men in the center of the French Quarter, which means that this story might not be appropriate for all children or maybe any of them. It acknowledges the existence of sex. Here's Nathaniel. We changed the name of the guy he's writing about in this story.
今天我们要报道的这一周恰好以世界艾滋病日开始。考虑到这一点，我们派出一名作家 Nathaniel Rich，去观察 NO/AIDS 进行 HIV 检测的最高风险场所之一——新奥尔良俱乐部（Club New Orleans），这是一个位于法国区中心地带的五层楼男子性俱乐部，这意味着这个故事可能不适合所有儿童，甚至可能不适合任何人。它承认了性行为的存在。这是 Nathaniel 的报道。我们更改了他在这个故事中提到的那个人的名字。
Room 300 was the largest bedroom in the club, just large enough to fit a chair and a queen size bed covered with red satin sheets. Sitting cross-legged on the bed was Alex Lee, a 25-year-old counselor for NO/AIDS, who's also a student at the University of New Orleans. He's majoring in anthropology. In fact, he had a final exam the next morning.
300 号房间是俱乐部里最大的卧室，刚好够放一把椅子和一张铺着红色缎面床单的大床。盘腿坐在床上的是 Alex Lee，一名 25 岁的 NO/AIDS 顾问，同时也是新奥尔良大学的学生。他主修人类学。事实上，他第二天早上还有一场期末考试。
When Mark entered the room, Alex was reading an essay about Occam's razor. Alex asked Mark to sit in the chair. He explained that the HIV test would only detect an infection that occurred more than three months ago. He showed Mark how to use an applicator to swab this mouth-- first his upper gums, then his lower gums. When Mark was finished, he dipped the end of the applicator into a small vial.
当 Mark 进入房间时，Alex 正在读一篇关于“奥卡姆剃刀”的文章。Alex 请 Mark 坐在椅子上。他解释说 HIV 检测只能检测到发生在三个多月前的感染。他向 Mark 展示了如何使用棉签擦拭口腔——先是上牙龈，然后是下牙龈。当 Mark 完成后，他将棉签末端浸入一个小瓶子中。
Alex set a timer to 20 minutes, the time it takes for a test result to appear, and placed it on the bedside table between them. He asked Mark a series of questions. "When was your last test?" "About a year ago," said Mark, "at a bar, in fact."
Alex 将计时器定为 20 分钟，这是检测结果出现所需的时间，并把它放在他们之间的床头柜上。他问了 Mark 一系列问题。“你上次检测是什么时候？”“大约一年前，”Mark 说，“事实上是在一家酒吧。”
"In the past 12 months," asked Alex, "have you had anal sex with a man?" "Yes," said Mark. "Have you had sex without using a condom?" "As a giver," said Mark. "How about sex with an anonymous, casual, or internet partner, someone you didn't know too well?" "I'm sure I have," said Mark.
“在过去 12 个月里，”Alex 问，“你有没有和男性发生过肛交？”“是的，”Mark 说。“你有没有在不使用避孕套的情况下发生性关系？”“作为主动方，”Mark 说。“有没有和匿名的、随意的或互联网伴侣发生性关系，那种你不太了解的人？”“我肯定有过，”Mark 说。
He seemed to become increasingly anxious. He crossed his arms, holding his elbows, hugging his chest. "Have you knowingly had sex with someone who's living with HIV?" "No." "Have you injected any drugs?" "No."
他看起来越来越焦虑。他交叉双臂，紧紧抱着胸口。“你是否明知对方患有艾滋病毒还与其发生性关系？”“没有。”“你注射过毒品吗？”“没有。”
"Have you had sex with someone who injects drugs?" Mark paused for two seconds. "No," he said. Alex started the next question, but Mark interrupted him. "Yes," he said, "yes, I have." "Sex with someone who injects drugs?" "Yeah. I just didn't know it until after."
“你有没有和注射过毒品的人发生性关系？”Mark 停顿了两秒钟。“没有，”他说。Alex 开始问下一个问题，但 Mark 打断了他。“是的，”他说，“是的，我有。”“和注射毒品的人发生性关系？”“是的。我直到事后才知道。”
The timer beeped. "Does that mean it's ready?" asked Mark. "No," said Alex. "It just beeps sometimes."
计时器发出哔哔声。“那意味着准备好了吗？”Mark 问。“不，”Alex 说。“有时候它就是会响。”
"It's so funny," said Mark, "and this is so crude, but I did have intercourse last night, not wearing a condom. It's just weird. The guy told me he was negative, but for some reason, after all was said and done, I thought he was really positive. And then I was thinking on the walk home how stupid that was."
“这太搞笑了，”Mark 说，“这很粗俗，但我确实昨晚发生了性行为，没戴避孕套。这太奇怪了。那个人告诉我他是阴性，但出于某种原因，一切结束后，我以为他是阳性。然后我在走回家的路上心想这太蠢了。”
Mark had been busy all day at work, so it had been easy to avoid thinking about it. But that evening, he went for a walk and soon found himself standing in front of the club. It was odd, Mark said, because he hadn't visited the club for a year. As soon as he stepped inside, a voice came on the loudspeaker announcing that there would be free HIV testing that evening. Suddenly, Mark understood why he had come to the club, and he felt scared.
Mark 整天在工作中很忙，所以很容易不去想这件事。但那天晚上，他去散步，很快发现自己站在俱乐部前面。这很奇怪，Mark 说，因为他已经有一年没去过那个俱乐部了。他一走进去，扬声器里就传来一个声音，宣布当晚有免费的 HIV 检测。突然，Mark 明白了自己为什么来到俱乐部，他感到很害怕。
There were five minutes left on the timer. "I'm really anxious," said Mark. He looked it. He was jittery. He rose from his chair. He said he was going to walk around and come back when his result was ready.
计时器还剩五分钟。“我真的很焦虑，”Mark 说。他看起来就是那样。他很焦躁。他从椅子上站起来。他说他要到处走走，等结果出来后再回来。
But five minutes later, when the timer went off, Mark was gone. Alex waited another 10 minutes, then another 10. A different man was tested, waited for his result, then left. Still no sign of Mark.
但五分钟后，当计时器响起时，Mark 已经不见了。Alex 又等了 10 分钟，接着又是 10 分钟。另一个男人接受了检测，等待结果，然后离开了。Mark 仍然没影。
Alex was mystified. In his two years testing men at bars, nobody had ever fled before finding out his results. It was now almost 11:30. His shift had official ended half an hour ago, and his anthropology final was at 10:00 AM.
Alex 很困惑。在他为酒吧男士检测的两年里，从来没有人会在知道结果之前逃跑。现在快 11:30 了。他的轮班半小时前正式结束了，而他的人类学期末考试是在早上 10:00。
As Alex gathered his testing materials, his colleague, Brandon, decided to make one final effort to find Mark. Brandon started in the gym. Mark wasn't there. Nor was Mark in the sauna or the whirlpool.
当 Alex 收拾检测材料时，他的同事 Brandon 决定做最后一次尝试来寻找 Mark。Brandon 从健身房开始找。Mark 不在那里。Mark 也不在桑拿房或漩涡浴缸里。
He was not in the room called the Bookstore, which doesn't have any books, nor was he in the Barracks. He was not in the so-called Porno Room, in which every surface is made of black rubber. And he was not in the Dungeon.
他不在名为“书店”的房间里，里面根本没有书，他也不在“军营”里。他不在所谓的“色情房”里，那里的每个表面都是用黑色橡胶制成的。他也不在“地牢”里。
Brandon paced through the narrow hallways, which are lined with more than 50 tiny bedrooms. Some of the doors were ajar. He saw harnesses and swings. He saw men watching videos.
Brandon 在狭窄的走廊里踱步，那里排列着 50 多个小卧室。有些门半开着。他看到了吊具和秋千。他看到男人们在看视频。
And then, in another bedroom, Brandon saw Mark. He was sitting on a bed, talking with a naked man. "Oh," said Mark, "are you looking for me?"
然后，在另一个卧室里，Brandon 看到了 Mark。他正坐在床上，和一个裸体男人交谈。“哦，”Mark 说，“你在找我吗？”
Five minutes later, Mark returned to room 300. His fingers were trembling. He was too nervous to sit. Alex told him that his test had come back negative.
五分钟后，Mark 回到了 300 号房间。他的手指在颤抖。他太紧张了，不敢坐下。Alex 告诉他检测结果是阴性。
"Yay!" Mark shouted. He was ecstatic. He asked Alex to show him the result on the test form. "God, I'm so happy. Thank you. Oh my god."
“太好了！”Mark 大喊。他欣喜若狂。他让 Alex 在检测表格上向他展示结果。“上帝，我太高兴了。谢谢你。噢天哪。”
He thanked Alex a few more times and said he was grateful for the work that NO/AIIDS was doing. Mark even said he wanted to volunteer for the organization, that he felt, as a member of the New Orleans gay community, it was the right thing to do. Then, negative test results in hand, he disappeared into the club.
他又感谢了 Alex 几次，并说他很感激 NO/AIDS 所做的工作。Mark 甚至说他想为该组织做志愿者，他觉得，作为新奥尔良同性恋社区的一员，这是正确的事情。然后，拿着阴性检测结果，他消失在俱乐部里。
Nathaniel Rich. He's the author of the forthcoming book Odds Against Tomorrow.
Nathaniel Rich。他是即将出版的书《胜算》（Odds Against Tomorrow）的作者。
[MUSIC - "ERASE" BY THE CHAINSMOKERS]
[音乐 - THE CHAINSMOKERS 的《ERASE》]
This, what you're listening to right now, is a Samantha Ronson remix, released this week by the Chainsmokers. Except for the Geto Boys, all the songs between stories today was a release or on albums that were released in the last seven days.
这首你现在正在听的歌，是由 The Chainsmokers 本周发布的 Samantha Ronson 的混音作品。除了 Geto Boys 的歌，今天故事之间的所有歌曲都是新发行的，或者是在过去七天里发布的专辑里的歌。
A week can be a long time, when every day seems to shift the direction of your entire country. Egypt has had a week of demonstrations, counter demonstrations, and violence. The demonstrations are for and against the country's president, Mohammed Morsi.
当每一天似乎都在改变整个国家的方向时，一周可能是一段很长的时间。埃及经历了一周的示威、反示威和暴力。示威活动是针对该国总统穆罕默德·穆尔西的支持者和反对者的。
And OK, quick review-- Morsi was democratically elected a couple months ago. But at the end of November, he shocked many Egyptians by issuing a decree giving himself enormous powers, basically putting all his decisions, past and present, above the law. He said he had to do this because judges appointed by Egypt's ousted dictator, Hosni Mubarak, were undermining him. Some of those judges had dissolved Egypt's newly elected parliament right before Morsi took office.
好了，快速回顾一下——穆尔西是几个月前民主选举产生的。但在 11 月底，他发布了一项法令，赋予自己巨大的权力，基本将他过去和现在的所有决定置于法律之上，这让许多埃及人感到震惊。他说他必须这样做，因为被赶下台的独裁者胡斯尼·穆巴拉克任命的法官正在破坏他。其中一些法官在穆尔西上任前不久解散了埃及新当选的议会。
So now, if you follow the news at all, you've seen this-- both sides are dug in, each convinced that they represent true democracy in Egypt. There are a lot of ways for things to get worse, very few for them to get better. Nancy Updike reports on what has happened and how some of the anger is being spread around.
所以现在，如果你关注新闻，你已经看到了这一点——双方都各执一词，每个人都确信他们代表了埃及真正的民主。事情恶化的方式有很多，变好的方式却很少。Nancy Updike 报道了发生了什么，以及一些愤怒是如何传播开来的。
Up until this past Wednesday, opponents and supporters of President Morsi had held their rallies in different places-- on purpose, to avoid confrontations. But late in the day on Wednesday, supporters of President Morsi, members of the Muslim Brotherhood, marched to the presidential palace, where some anti-Morsi protesters were camped out. And after that, all night long, people fought or ran or hid.
直到上周三，总统穆尔西的反对者和支持者一直在不同的地方举行集会——这是故意的，为了避免对抗。但在周三晚些时候，总统穆尔西的支持者，穆斯林兄弟会的成员，游行到总统府，一些反穆尔西的抗议者在那里露营。此后，整夜，人们一直在战斗、奔跑或躲藏。
By Thursday morning, seven people were dead, and hundreds were injured. And four of Morsi's advisers had resigned in protest. As of right now, Friday evening, around 6:00 PM Egypt time, the leaders of both sides aren't talking to each other, and protesters are still in the streets, separate and peaceful for the moment.
到周四早上，七人死亡，数百人受伤。穆尔西的四名顾问辞职以示抗议。截至目前，周五晚上，埃及时间下午 6:00 左右，双方领导人互不交谈，抗议者仍留在街头，目前暂时分开且和平。
When I was in Cairo after Mubarak was ousted last year, I saw a scene that now seems impossible-- writers and editors, secular Egyptians, who were talking over croissants with members of a formerly violent Islamist group named Gamaa Islamiya, an ally of the Muslim Brotherhood. The secular men and the devout men weren't becoming friends. But they weren't beating each other up in the streets, either.
去年穆巴拉克被赶下台后，我在开罗时，看到了一个现在看起来不可能的场景——作家和编辑，世俗的埃及人，正在和以前一个暴力伊斯兰组织“伊斯兰集团”（Gamaa Islamiya）的成员，即穆斯林兄弟会的盟友，一起吃牛角面包。那些世俗的人和虔诚的人并没有成为朋友。但他们也没有在街上互殴。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
Hello?
喂？
[SPEAKING ARABIC].
[讲阿拉伯语]。
On Thursday night, I made a phone call through an interpreter. She was shouting a bit to make herself heard. And we called one of the people from that meeting, an Egyptian novelist in his 70s named Yusuf al-Qaid to find out his take on the week's events. He remembered me, but he wanted to make absolutely sure I knew where he stands in this fight.
周四晚上，我通过翻译打了一个电话。她喊得有点响以便让我听到。我们给那次会议中的一个人打了电话，一位 70 多岁的埃及小说家 Yusuf al-Qaid，想了解他对本周事件的看法。他记得我，但他想百分之百确保我知道他在这场斗争中的立场。
[SPEAKING ARABIC].
[讲阿拉伯语]。
I would like our American journalist here to understand that I am not in any neutral position here. I am with a civilian modern state. I am against a religious state. I am against any rule based on religion.
我希望我们的美国记者了解，我在这里没有任何中立立场。我支持一个世俗的现代国家。我反对一个宗教国家。我反对任何基于宗教的统治。
So against Morsi. And since he brought up the fact that I'm American, I told al-Qaid that I'd seen pictures of anti-Morsi protesters, people like him, carrying signs talking about the US and President Obama. I didn't mention this specific one to him, but I saw a sign that said, "Obama, your bitch is our dictator." The vehemence of al-Qaid's response caught me by surprise.
所以他反对穆尔西。既然他提到了我是美国人这一事实，我告诉 al-Qaid，我看到了反穆尔西抗议者的照片，像他这样的人，举着谈论美国和奥巴马总统的标语。我没有具体向他提及那一条，但我看到一个标语写着，“奥巴马，你的婊子是我们的独裁者。”Al-Qaid 回应的猛烈程度让我感到惊讶。
In my view, the biggest betrayal that has taken place against the Egyptian people is the absolute support that the American administration has given to the Muslim Brotherhood. America is ignoring the violence that is conducted against the Egyptian people. America is completely silent and has voiced that its relationship with Egypt is strategic. And therefore, passing events do not affect this strategic relationship.
在我看来，对埃及人民最大的背叛是美国政府对穆斯林兄弟会的绝对支持。美国无视对埃及人民进行的暴力行为。美国保持完全沉默，并表示它与埃及的关系是战略性的。因此，发生的事件不影响这种战略关系。
By strategic relationship, he means that the United States is more concerned about Egypt's dealings with Israel than about Egypt's dealings with its own citizens. This week, more than ever, I realized that no matter how angry and caught up in their own national issues a person is, depending on what country they're in, they probably still have plenty of anger left over for the United States.
所谓战略关系，他的意思是美国更关心埃及与以色列的交易，而不是埃及与本国公民的交易。本周，我比以往任何时候都更意识到，无论一个人多么愤怒并沉浸在他们自己的国家事务中，取决于他们所在的国家，他们可能仍然会对美国怀有充足的余怒。
After I hung up with al-Qaid, I called another person I met in Cairo last year-- completely different guy, a religious man, young, 28 years old, named Mohammed Agiba. Mohammed spent years in the Muslim Brotherhood. But now he's marching against Morsi too. He knew Morsi's power grab would divide the country. And he thinks the proposed constitution is a disaster that has to be stopped.
在和 al-Qaid 通完话后，我给去年我在开罗遇到的另一个人打了电话——一个完全不同的人，一个虔诚的人，年轻，28 岁，名叫 Mohammed Agiba。Mohammed 在穆斯林兄弟会待了多年。但现在他也加入了反穆尔西的游行。他知道穆尔西攫取权力会分裂这个国家。他认为提议的宪法是一场必须阻止的灾难。
And talking about the constitution is when we ended up at the same place I ended up with al-Qaid, the secular guy. Mohammed talked about how the constitution calls for a joint civilian military council, weighted toward the military, that has to be consulted before the president can declare a war. The council also has a role in deciding on the military's budget. Mohammed sees the council as one thing only.
谈到宪法时，我们最终得出了我和世俗人士 al-Qaid 相同的结论。Mohammed 谈到宪法如何呼吁建立一个偏向军方的联合民事军事委员会，在总统宣布战争前必须咨询该委员会。该委员会在决定军费预算方面也发挥作用。Mohammed 认为这个委员会只有一种功能。
[SPEAKING ARABIC].
[讲阿拉伯语]。
This is what the US wants; this is what Israel wants-- a regime which appears to be democratic to the people, but actually it is this defense national council which will be doing all the work. This council, the National Defense Council, will be the one ruling the country.
这就是美国想要的；这就是以色列想要的——一个看起来对人民民主的政权，但实际上是这个国防国家委员会在做所有工作。这个委员会，国防国家委员会，将是统治这个国家的机构。
So are you saying you think President Morsi or part of his government or all of his government are puppets of the United States?
所以你是说你认为总统穆尔西或他政府的一部分或整个政府是美国的傀儡吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC].
[讲阿拉伯语]。
For sure President Morsi wants the interests of Egypt. However, he sees the implementation of this interest, or finding the interest, from a very narrow perspective that the United States has set for him. We do not want him to see that perspective through the United States' perspective.
总统穆尔西肯定想要埃及的利益。然而，他从美国为他设定的一个非常狭隘的视角来看待这种利益的实现，或寻找这种利益。我们不想让他透过美国的视角来看待那个视角。
We want him to see it through the Egyptian people's vision and through the Egyptian people's perspective. And we say, please, the Egyptian people should be your priority and not the American administration.
我们想要他透过埃及人民的愿景和埃及人民的视角来看待它。我们说，请，埃及人民应该是你的优先事项，而不是美国政府。
I asked Mohammed one more question, not about America, but about Egypt and the choices people have faced there since the revolution. I asked him if he'd voted for Morsi. He did, like a lot of people who are now protesting against Morsi.
我又问了 Mohammed 一个问题，不是关于美国，而是关于埃及以及自革命以来人们面临的选择。我问他是否投票给了穆尔西。他投了，像许多现在抗议穆尔西的人一样。
He said he doesn't regret it. The alternative was worse. He says he just hopes Morsi can pull out of this and pull Egypt out too.
他说他不后悔。替代方案更糟。他说他只是希望穆尔西能从这一切中退出，并把埃及也拉出来。
Nancy Updike. She's one of the producers of our show.
Nancy Updike。她是我们节目的制片人之一。
OK, let's go back to America. Friday morning, Boston, Logan Airport, 5:40 AM.
好的，让我们回到美国。周五早上，波士顿，洛根机场，凌晨 5:40。
Delta. United.
达美。联合。
30 times a night, six nights a week, Fred Beaton drives the shuttle bus on the same loop, from the parking garage to the terminals, picking people up, dropping them off, every 20 minutes, same loop. He's been doing this for 16 years, till this morning. He's retiring.
Fred Beaton 每晚 30 次，每周 6 天，都在相同的回路上驾驶穿梭巴士，从停车场到航站楼，接人、送人，每 20 分钟一次，相同的回路。他做了 16 年了，直到今天早上。他要退休了。
Hopefully, this is my last trip around the airport.
希望这是我最后一次绕机场飞行了。
Freddie B, you'll never be done here, never.
Freddie B，你永远不会在这里结束，永远不会。
That one was his boss, Vinny, over the radio.
那是他的老板 Vinny，在无线电中说的。
Off to the sunset.
奔向夕阳。
But everybody got in on it.
但每个人都参与进来了。
Freddie B's last ride. [EVIL LAUGH].
Freddie B 的最后一次旅程。[邪恶的笑声]。
So do you feel sad at all, nostalgic, maybe?
所以你感到悲伤、怀旧吗，也许？
No, I don't feel sad. No.
不，我不觉得悲伤。不。
Not even a little bit?
一点也不？
I'm glad, happy. It's somebody else's turn.
我很高兴，开心。轮到别人了。
His stepson, Ryan Murdoch, is riding with him, making this recording and talking to him. They calculate that he's done this loop 128,000 times in 16 years. And at 6 o'clock, when he gets to the end of his very last ride, the guy who was supposed to show up was late.
他的继子 Ryan Murdoch 和他一起坐车，进行录音并和他谈话。他们计算出他在 16 年里完成了 128,000 次这个回路。在 6 点钟，当他完成最后一次行程时，本该出现的人迟到了。
So he has to do one more. Perfect, right? And then he gets to pull the shuttle bus over one last, last time, and climb out.
所以他不得不又做了一次。完美，对吧？然后他终于可以把穿梭巴士最后停下来，爬出去了。
All right. Hey, glory Hallelujah. I'll see you.
好的。嘿，荣耀哈利路亚。再见。
Best of luck, Freddie.
祝好运，Freddie。
Take care.
保重。
Nice working with you, my friend.
很高兴和你一起工作，我的朋友。
Yeah.
是的。
All right, we're done.
好了，我们结束了。
We're done.
我们结束了。
You've got a huge smile on your face.
你脸上挂着巨大的笑容。
Good. Getting out of  here, you know?
好极了。要从这里解脱了，你知道吗？
In Chicago, Linc Cohen began his retirement this week. He worked at a steel mill for 18 years, and then for 20 years after, for the union AFSCME. Monday was his first day home as a retired person. And his wife, Sandi Wisenberg, had some questions. She recorded them.
在芝加哥，Linc Cohen 本周开始了退休生活。他在钢铁厂工作了 18 年，然后为 AFSCME 工会工作了 20 年。周一是他作为退休人员在家的第一天。他的妻子 Sandi Wisenberg 有几个问题。她录了下来。
Are you going to make the bed? You can make the bed now.
你要铺床吗？你现在可以铺床了。
Well, you got up after me today.
嗯，你今天起得比我晚。
But I never make it.
但我从不铺床。
I know. When I get up last-- the day before, I got up after you, and I made it.
我知道。当我最后起时——前一天，我起得比你晚，我就铺了。
Right. But what if I get up last, and then you're still here. You can go up and make it.
对。但如果我最后才起呢，而你还在那儿。你可以去把它铺了。
Yeah, I might. I might not.
是的，我可能会。也可能不会。
Oh, I thought you don't like it when it's not made.
哦，我以为你不喜欢不铺床。
I don't like it when it's not made. But I also don't like cleaning up your messes. I have enough of that to do.
我不喜欢不铺床。但我也不喜欢清理你的烂摊子。我已经有足够多要做的事了。
[CELL PHONE ALARM]
[手机闹钟]
In other news with people not getting to work in the morning-- Springfield, Oregon, Monday morning of this week, 7:30, a grad student named Morgan Peach hears the alarm that is supposed to wake him up. Then he shuts it off. This happens again at 7:35--
关于人们早上无法上班的其他新闻——俄勒冈州斯普林菲尔德，本周一早上 7:30，一个叫 Morgan Peach 的研究生听到了本该叫醒他的闹钟。然后他关掉了。这在 7:35 又发生了一次——
[CELL PHONE ALARM]
[手机闹钟]
--and then again at 7:40.
——然后是 7:40。
[GROANS].
[呻吟声]。
[CELL PHONE ALARM]
[手机闹钟]
Once more at 7:45.
7:45 又来一次。
[CELL PHONE ALARM]
[手机闹钟]
You get the idea. 8:15, 8:25. Finally, 9 o'clock, his girlfriend Angela Evancie, who made this recording, steps in.
你明白意思了。8:15，8:25。最后，9 点，他的女朋友 Angela Evancie，制作了这个录音的人，介入了。
It's time?
时间到了？
It's time.
时间到了。
He doesn't get up. It's finals week. Besides an exam, he has two research papers to turn in and 55 exams and papers to grade. Angela sees him struggle every day with waking up. But she thought, this week, this week, for once, he would do it when the alarm sounds, because he has so much to do.
他没起床。这是期末考试周。除了考试，他还有两篇研究论文要交，还有 55 份考试和论文要评分。Angela 每天都看着他挣扎着起床。但她想，这周，这周，破天荒地，他会在闹钟响起时起床，因为他有太多事要做。
Tuesday, it goes off first at 7:30, then seven more times-- 7:40, 7:45, 8 o'clock, 8:05, 8:10, 8:15, 8:20. Wednesday, pretty much the same deal. At some point, Angela says to her sleeping boyfriend--
周二，闹钟先在 7:30 响起，然后又响了七次——7:40、7:45、8:00、8:05、8:10、8:15、8:20。周三，情况基本相同。在某个时候，Angela 对着熟睡的男朋友说——
Did you set the alarm for 9 o'clock?
你把闹钟设在 9 点了吗？
Yes, I did.
是的，我设了。
Can you afford to sleep in that late?
你起得起这么晚吗？
I certainly can. I'm wealthy in time, not in money.
我绝对可以。我在时间上很富有，钱上不富有。
Wednesday night, Morgan tells Angela that the next morning, Thursday, he actually is going to have to get up early. A geography paper is due at noon.
周三晚上，Morgan 告诉 Angela，第二天早上，也就是周四，他确实得早起。地理论文中午截止。
Yeah, could you set the alarm for 7:30 tomorrow? I'd like to get up at 7:30 and work on my research papers and finish them.
是的，明天你能把闹钟设在 7:30 吗？我想在 7:30 起床，完成我的研究论文。
Hours pass.
时间流逝。
And now it's 8:00. The alarm went off, and he reset it for 8:30. I really thought he was going to do it this morning.
现在是 8:00 了。闹钟响了，他把它重设为 8:30。我真的以为他今天早上会起床的。
Sometime near 10:00 AM, they finally have this conversation.
大约在上午 10:00，他们终于进行了这次对话。
It's time to get up.
是时候起床了。
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
And then, still lying in bed, he explains the whole thing perfectly. It would be impossible to say this better.
然后，仍然躺在床上，他完美地解释了整件事。如果说得更好是不可能的。
It's almost as if the sleeping is that much sweeter when you have to get up or you think you have to get up, and then you don't.
这几乎就好像，当你必须起床或者你以为你必须起床，然后你又不用起的时候，睡觉感觉特别甜。
[MUSIC - "LOVER TO LOVER" BY FLORENCE AND THE MACHINE]
[音乐 - FLORENCE AND THE MACHINE 的《LOVER TO LOVER》]
Well, our program was produced this week by Sarah Koenig, our senior producer, Julie Snyder, and me, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robin Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Production help from Tarek Fouda. Amy Phillips, from Pitchfork Media, was our music consultant, finding brand new songs. Seth Lind is our operations director. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant.
嗯，我们的节目本周由我们的资深制片人 Sarah Koenig、Julie Snyder 和我制作，参与者还有 Alex Blumberg、Ben Calhoun、Jonathan Menjivar、Lisa Pollak、Brian Reed、Robin Semien、Alissa Shipp 和 Nancy Updike。制作协助来自 Tarek Fouda。来自 Pitchfork Media 的 Amy Phillips 是我们的音乐顾问，负责寻找全新的歌曲。Seth Lind 是我们的运营总监。Elise Bergerson 是我们的行政助理。
At our website this week, we have a gallery of photos taken on Instagram by people all over the world in these last seven days of events large and small. Emily Condon on our staff did the photo curating. She did so good. You should look. That's at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
在本周我们的网站上，我们有一个 Instagram 照片库，由世界各地的人们在过去七天里拍摄的大大小小的事件组成。我们员工中的 Emily Condon 负责照片策展。她做得太棒了。你应该看看。那是我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. And our film Sleepwalk With Me is now available for download at iTunes-- itunes.com/sleepwalkwithme. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who never stops saying--
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。我们的电影《与我梦游》（Sleepwalk With Me）现在可以在 iTunes 上下载——itunes.com/sleepwalkwithme。我们节目的 WBEZ 管理层由我们的老板 Torey Malatia 先生监督，他从不停止说——
F This American Life . What the hell are you going to do with This American Life when you're dead?
去他妈的《美国生活》。你死后对《美国生活》能做什么？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是 Ira Glass。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。